عاد بعد أن استيقظوا واه
مكث شهرًا للتعافي من هذه
الإصابة ثم عانوا قليلاً كان
لديه مشاكل أخرى في بلده أه أه نعم
في مشاكل أخرى
مشكلة جسدية أخرى نعم لكني
أكرر
والمدرب هو  المدرب ليس غبيًا جدًا ،
إنهم جميعًا المدرب واه ليسوا
أغبياء جدًا لا تبدأ مع الأفضل
11. أريد أن أفوز ،
لا يهمني إذا
كنت من سوني أه
أه كين
ريتشاردسون
أريد أن أفوز.
تريد الفوز
ثم في نفس الوقت يجب أن أتحمل
المسؤولية لاتخاذ القرار الأفضل
لأن أه إذا كنت لاعبًا واحدًا تحتاج إلى
وقت للتعافي حتى تكون لائقًا
ونحتاج للحصول على النقاط نحتاج للفوز
في كل  لعبة
وأنا أفهم أنه إذا تحدثت مع
لاعبي الفرق القديمة فإنهم يريدون
لعب كل مباراة وكل مباراة وكل مباراة
أيضًا عندما يكونون متعبين.